ese es el salto más grande que hemos
dado en la región en términos
humanitarios y de apoyo a una población
que la viene pasando mal una población
que se ha visto forzada a salir de su
país y que de esta forma tendremos una
mano amiga en representación del
presidente iván duque para que logren
construir un mejor futuro un mejor
presente en una nación que les da la
mano repudia la dictadura pero atiende
las necesidades del pueblo migrante
venezolano
a francisco porque este plan se anuncia
hasta ahora y podría este proyecto
incentivar más migraciones regular
bueno lo primero es que este es un
trabajo de gobierno coordinado de
muchísimos meses en el mundo a nivel
internacional estatutos temporal de
protección tiene en eeuu y turquía se
convierte colombia en la tercera nación
en un hecho sin precedentes en las
américas para este tipo de procedimiento
eso nos toma tiempo porque es una
decisión responsable lo segundo la
migración venezolano es una realidad
colombia y venezuela comparten una
frontera de más de 2.200 kilómetros y
unas necesidades apremiantes de esta
población que los expulsan de su país
por eso esto no es un incentivo para la
migración irregular es una red expuesta
humanitaria bajo criterios de la oficina
del alto comisionado de las naciones
unidas para los refugiados ha apoyado en
la literatura y en la técnica que va a
permitir construir presente y futuro por
eso esto no aplica para quienes intenten
pasar por puntos contrarios a la ley o
por trochas esto aplicará para aquellos
migrantes que estén en el territorio
nacional o que están a corte 31 de enero
aquellos que ingresen de manera formal
durante los próximos dos años con
francisco espinoza director de migración
colombia muchas gracias por acompañarnos
en france 24